.
Wenn Dunkelheit
und Ruhe einkehren ...
... und dem ganzen Land eine ge-
heimnisvolle Schönheit verleihen ...
... wenn die einen bereits schlafen,
erzählen die anderen
ihre Geschichten.
Geschichten, einzigartig
und verborgen, kommen zum Vorschein.
Auf unserer Reise durch eine
winterliche Nacht in der Schweiz.
Von der Dämmerung
bis zum Morgengrauen.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Ein Wintertag im Oberengadin
geht zu Ende.
Mariella Cotti
auf dem Weg zur Arbeit.
Ihr Arbeitsplatz liegt
auf 3'300 m ü.M. auf dem Corvatsch.
Sobald man die Bahn betritt
und losfährt,
hat man ein schönes Gefühl,
wenn man den Sonnenuntergang sieht.
Dann freut man sich auf die Arbeit.
Ihre Arbeit beginnt mit dem Check
des über 8 t schweren Fahrzeugs.
Die Maschine muss man kennen
und wissen, wie damit umgehen.
Ich bin Landwirtin.
Dadurch ist es für mich einfacher.
Ich kenne den Umgang
mit den Maschinen.
* Der Motor startet. *
Eigentlich arbeitet Mariella
auf dem Hof der Eltern.
Doch im Winter
gibt es dort weniger zu tun
und so präpariert sie
die Pisten des Skigebiets.
Es ist bereits ihre elfte Saison.
Ich wollte eigentlich nicht
Pistenbullyfahrerin werden.
Ich wollte nur einmal mitfahren,
weil mich Maschinen faszinieren.
Ich hätte es mir gar nicht
zugetraut, selber zu fahren.
Der damalige Chef,
der mit mitgenommen hat, fand,
ich solle fahren.
Erst weigerte ich mich.
Aber er sagte,
ich fahre ja auch andere Maschinen.
Also probierte ich es,
und da packte mich das Fieber.
"Helden der Nacht"
werden die Bullyfahrer genannt.
Am Corvatsch präparieren sie
jede Nacht 56 Pistenkilometer.
Für mich ist es ein Nebenverdienst,
aber es ist auch eine Leidenschaft.
Ich könnte auch etwas Einfacheres
machen und tagsüber arbeiten,
aber ich bevorzuge die Nachtarbeit.
Unten im Tal: St. Moritz.
* Sanfte Musik *
Sie war die erste Gemeinde
in der Schweiz,
die elektrisches Licht hatte.
Möglich machte das Johannes Badrutt.
Knapp 20 Jahre später eröffnete sein
Sohn Caspar das Badrutt's Palace.
Immer noch d e r Treffpunkt
des internationalen Jetsets.
Mit Suiten für gerne mal 25'000 Fr. -
pro Nacht.
Zurück auf dem Corvatsch.
Ein Berg im Scheinwerferlicht.
Nachtskifahren, jeden Freitag,
auf der längsten beleuchteten Abfahrt
der Schweiz.
* Sanfte, verspielte Musik *
Die Pistenfahrzeuge
sind in solchen Nächten
praktisch rund um die Uhr im Einsatz.
Ich bin die einzige Frau im Team,
aber mir gefällt es
als Frau in einem Männerteam.
Es ist schon besonders
als Frau in einem Team.
Es ist ein schöner Status.
Es sorgen sich alle um mich,
wenn ich ein Problem habe,
wird mir sofort geholfen.
Ein Mann ist eher
auf sich allein gestellt.
Über Funk sind alle Bullyfahrer
miteinander verbunden.
Das Team ist wie eine Familie.
Das ist vergleichbar.
Alle arbeiten in der Nacht.
Alle leben ein wenig
am normalen Leben vorbei.
Darum sind wir in der Nacht
schon ein bisschen eine Familie.
Erst um 4 Uhr morgens
wird Mariella heute Schluss machen.
Am Fusse des Corvatsch: Silvaplana.
Tennis- und Fussballplätze sind unter
einer dicken Eisschicht verborgen.
Wie eine leuchtende Schlange
in der Dunkelheit.
Autoscheinwerfer auf den Serpentinen
hoch Richtung Julierpass.
Die Hauptstrasse Nummer 3
führt von Castasegna
an der italienischen Grenze
im Bergell
über Chur und Zürich bis nach Basel.
Inmitten der rauen Berglandschaft
auf 2'300 m Höhe: das Theater Origen.
Im roten Holzturm blickt man hinab
auf eine schwebende Bühne.
Gleich daneben:
der Lej da las Culuonnas.
Benannt nach den Säulen
eines römischen Heiligtums,
die bei Grabungen
hier entdeckt wurden.
Unten im Bündner Rheintal: Domat-Ems,
das Industriezentrum des Kantons.
In der EMS-CHEMIE
werden 365 Tage rund um die Uhr
Hochleistungswerkstoffe produziert,
v.a. Granulat für die Automobil-,
Elektronik- und Verpackungsindustrie.
15 km westlich: Flims und Laax.
Der Crap Sogn Gion mit
seiner raumschiffartigen Bergstation.
Auf 2'300 m ü.M.
kann man auch übernachten.
Mit einer wunderbaren Sicht ins Tal.
Keine 60 km Luftlinie weiter
südwestlich in der Leventina: Airolo.
Die Südseite des Gotthards war
für das Schweizer Militär seit jeher
von strategischer Bedeutung.
Darum auch die vielen Festungen.
1995 kam die Kaserne Bedrina hinzu.
600 Sanitätsrekruten
sind in Airolo einquartiert.
Heute steht ein Nachtmarsch an.
Leutnant Vivien Hofer
hat das Kommando über Rekruten
aus allen Sprachregionen.
Seit ich fünf Jahre alt war,
wollte ich auch ins Militär.
Mein Vater war dort.
Dann ...
... mussten sich meine Freunde
damit beschäftigen.
Dann habe ich mich entschieden,
auch das Militär zu machen.
Vivien Hofer ist 23 Jahre alt
und befehligt bis zu 200 Rekruten.
* Rufe auf Französisch *
Wir machen es so:
Wenn der erste Lastwagen
gefahren ist, fahren wir auch.
Sie sind seit vier Wochen
in der Ausbildung
und absolvieren heute
ihre erste Nachtübung.
Einen 10-km-Marsch.
Die grösste Herausforderung
für die Truppe wird die Kälte
und der letzte Marschteil sein.
Dieser ist steil.
Wenn sie frieren und müde sind,
kann das auf die Motivation drücken.
Aber das werden wir schon auffangen.
* Hüpfende Musik *
Lastwagen übernehmen das Verschieben,
den Transport der Rekruten
zum Abmarschort.
Die meisten der angehenden Soldaten
sind junge Männer.
Doch der Anteil der Frauen
in der Schweizer Armee steigt.
Viele von ihnen
übernehmen Führungsaufgaben.
Es gilt der Grundsatz:
gleiche Leistung, gleiche Chancen.
Allumez votre lampe frontière!
Alors, bon marche!
- (Alle) Merci.
Es kommen keine dummen Sprüche.
Die Gleichberechtigung
steht an oberster Stelle.
Das gefällt mir.
Es ist eine kalte Februarnacht.
Die Vorgesetzten
begleiten den Marsch im Auto.
Filippo Boo ist Hauptmann.
Er ist verantwortlich
für die Ausbildung der Rekruten.
Nachtarbeit ist für ihn Routine.
(Italienisch)
In der Kälte der Nacht
treffen die Rekruten
auf einen ersten Verpflegungsposten.
Es gibt Tee, Obst und Schokoriegel.
Leutnant Vivien Hofer ist zufrieden.
Bis jetzt keine Zwischenfälle.
Alles läuft nach Plan.
Das sind meine Rekruten,
sie sind wie meine Kinder.
Auf den Märschen
bin ich immer etwas nervös,
ob es allen gut geht,
ob sie den Marsch absolvieren.
Ob sie überhaupt zu Ende laufen.
Wenn es Leute mit Problemen gibt,
ist man als Kompaniekommandant
mit Herz und Seele dabei.
Die Truppe
beschwört den Zusammenhalt.
* Anfeuerungsrufe *
(Italienisch)
Noch liegt ein ordentliches Stück Weg
vor ihnen,
bis zu einer Unterkunft
in einem ehemaligen Pferdestall.
Dort werden sie ein paar Stunden
ausruhen dürfen.
* Sanfte Musik *
Nur rund 50 km
nördlich des Gotthards:
über dem Pilatus
ein majestätischer Blick auf Luzern.
* Knall *
Der Urknall am Schmutzige Donnschtig.
Luzern im Ausnahmezustand.
Fritschi-Umzug, Güdismäntig
und Monstercorso -
für rund 200'000 Luzernerinnen
und Luzerner
sind diese sechs Tage und Nächte
der Höhepunkt des Jahres.
* Rhythmisches Trommeln *
Erst am Morgen des Aschermittwochs
findet das bunte Treiben ein Ende.
* Sanfte Musik *
Über den Pilatus Richtung Süden.
In wenigen Flugminuten
ist man im Berner Oberland.
Gadmen am Fusse des Sustenpasses
ist im Februar
Kulisse eines besonderen Spektakels:
eines Schlittenhunderennens.
Alain Hauert
nimmt schon das fünfte Mal
an der nächtlichen Gadmer Trophy
teil.
* Besänftigungsrufe *
Vor zehn Jahren
hatte ich noch Angst vor Hunden.
Heute habe ich wegen meiner
Partnerin Vivienne Schlittenhunde,
die schon von klein auf
Husky-Fan ist.
Sie kaufte den ersten Hund,
ich rutschte da rein.
Alains Partnerin, Vivienne Décorvet,
besitzt inzwischen elf Hunde
aus eigener Zucht.
Ich fuhr schon mit sieben Jahren
die ersten Kinderrennen.
Jetzt bin ich 37 und bin immer noch
Schlittenhunde-Fan.
Das ist meine Sucht, die bis
zu meinem Lebensende anhalten wird.
(Speaker) Wir wünschen all the best!
Go! Go! Go, Alain!
7 km lang ist die Strecke.
Der Fahrer, genannt Musher, lenkt die
Hunde nur mit gerufenen Kommandos.
Das Kopflicht des Mushers
weist den Hunden den Weg.
* Sanfte Musik *
Sie laufen sehr gerne in der Nacht.
Es ist ein anderes Feeling
für die Hunde als während des Tages,
auch wegen der Tiere in der Wildnis.
In der Dunkelheit
müssen sich Musher und Hunde
noch mehr aufeinander verlassen
als bei Rennen am Tag.
Die Gadmer Trophy
ist ein besonderer Wettbewerb.
Es geht nicht nur um Schnelligkeit,
sondern auch um Geschick.
Es ist ein Anlass
wider den tierischen Ernst.
Wir freuen uns an unseren Hunden,
sind draussen,
es ist Nacht und Winter -
ein toller Event.
Die Hunde erreichen bis zu 40 km/h.
Damit die Tiere fit sind,
müssen Alain und Vivienne
jeden Tag mit ihnen trainieren.
Sie können eigentlich
immer durchhalten.
Sie können bis zum Tod rennen.
Man muss sie selber bremsen,
sonst würden sie
ununterbrochen rennen.
Das ist ihre Leidenschaft.
Nach einer knappen Stunde
erreicht Alain das Ziel.
Heja, heja!
Heja, heja, das war gut.
- Das war gut.
Super, Inari.
Noch schnell die Hunde versorgen,
dann kommt der gemütliche Teil
der Nacht.
* Sanfte Musik *
Man ist in der Wildnis.
Die Stimmung ist immer cool,
weil viele Menschen hier sind.
Die Nacht-Trophy ist das Highlight
dieses Wochenendes.
* Sanfte Musik *
Seit mehr als 20 Jahren leuchtet
dieser Stern auf dem Harder Kulm.
Als vorweihnachtlicher Gruss gedacht
ist er zur Winterbeleuchtung des
Hausbergs von Interlaken geworden.
Interlaken,
ein Topspot für Touristen,
verzeichnet in guten Jahren
bis 3 Mio. Logiernächte.
Weit herum bekannt:
das Victoria-Jungfrau Grand Hotel.
* Sanfte Musik *
In der Dunkelheit
nur schemenhaft zu erkennen:
die berühmtesten drei Gipfel
der Region:
Eiger, Mönch und Jungfrau.
Das Wahrzeichen von Lauterbrunnen:
der Staubbachfall.
In der Hochsaison
ist er auch nachts zugänglich.
Auf dem Schilthorn thront die
Bergstation mit Panorama-Restaurant.
Unvergesslich:
James Bonds Verfolgungsjagden 1969
im Geheimdienst ihrer Majestät.
Unterhalb des knapp 3'000 m
hohen Gipfelrestaurants
werden auch hier Pisten präpariert.
* Instrumentalversion
der "James Bond"-Titelmelodie *
Die einzige direkte Verbindung
vom Berner Oberland ins Wallis
ist immer noch der Lötschbergtunnel.
Seit 2007
dauert die Fahrt nur noch 15 Min.
Alexander Ebener ist für das Be-
und Entladen der Züge zuständig.
Wir sind hier
quasi so etwas wie Polizisten.
Um den Verkehr zu regeln.
Man muss den Leuten zeigen,
wo sie hinfahren müssen,
obwohl alles gut signalisiert ist.
Auf der Rampe muss man die Leute ...
... instruieren.
Sonst kommt es hier nicht gut.
Sonst gibt es viel Blechschaden.
Alexander Ebener und seine Kollegen
schleusen jährlich
mehr als 1 Mio. Fahrzeuge
durch den 34 km langen Lötschberg.
Der Fahrplan ist eng getaktet.
Die Züge fahren jede halbe Stunde,
in Stosszeiten sogar alle 15 Min.
Die grosse Verantwortung
liegt im Zeitplan:
dass der Zug rechtzeitig abfährt.
Und dass die Autos richtig verladen
sind, richtig auf dem Zug stehen,
damit es keine Überbrückung gibt.
Das ist die grosse Herausforderung.
Und Kundenfreundlichkeit.
Man sollte immer ein schönes
Lächeln ... für die Kunden haben.
Heute ist Mittwoch,
da ist der Andrang nicht so gross.
Hochbetrieb
herrscht an den Wochenenden,
v.a. während der Winterferien.
Da wollen bis zu 10'000 Fahrzeuge
täglich auf den Verlad.
Alexander
arbeitet allein in der Spätschicht.
Ihm bleibt keine Zeit,
die Autos ordnungsgemäss einzuweisen,
denn er gibt auch das Signal
zur Abfahrt der Züge.
Das ist ein Wagen,
und hier sind zwei Autos drauf.
Hier hätten eigentlich
vier bis fünf Autos Platz.
Er ist allein, schau.
Der nächste ist hier.
Wenn kein Einweiser da ist, wird
keine Rücksicht genommen. Leider.
Da zählt nur, dass man
auf dem Zug ist, der Rest ... egal.
1926 wurden erstmals Fahrzeuge
durch den Lötschberg transportiert.
Alexanders Familie ist Teil
dieser Lötschberg-Geschichte.
Der Grossvater war das Vorbild.
Das hier ist mein Grossvater.
Er war Betriebsmitarbeiter der BLS.
So wurden früher die Autos verladen.
Ohne Dach.
Hier musste man mit Holzkeilen
die Autos verkeilen.
Pro Tag gab es vielleicht einen Zug.
Damals war der Autoverlad
noch rund um die Uhr in Betrieb.
Doch die Zeiten haben sich geändert.
Heute herrschen in Kandersteg
und Goppenstein 6 Std. Nachtruhe.
Durch die Automatisierung
ist alles in Spiez
und läuft ferngesteuert
von dort aus.
Das ganze BLS-Netz.
Dadurch ist in Goppenstein
niemand mehr.
Um 23.30 Uhr sind wir die Letzten,
die hier sind.
* Sanfte Musik *
Auf der Grenze zwischen den Kantonen
Bern und Wallis -
einer der magischsten Orte
der Schweiz:
das Jungfraujoch
mit der Felsenkuppe Sphinx.
Das Observatorium
liegt auf 3'571 m Höhe.
Zusammen mit der Endstation
der Jungfraubahn
Ziel von etwa 1 Mio. Touristen
jedes Jahr.
Der mächtigste Eisstrom der Alpen:
der Aletschgletscher.
Die Klimaerwärmung setzt ihm zu.
Einst lag die Konkordiahütte nur
wenige Meter über dem Gletscherrand.
Heute thront sie gut 150 m
über dem Konkordiaplatz
mit seinem rund 800 m dicken Eis.
Klima- und Gletscherforscher rechnen,
dass der Gletscher in 80 Jahren
wohl ganz verschwunden sein wird.
Die Bergkulisse im Wallis.
Umrahmt von Viertausendern
liegt Saas-Fee.
Hier gibt es noch eine der wenigen
Natureisbahnen der Schweiz.
Otto Zengaffinen ist der Eismeister.
Seit mehr als 30 Jahren.
War das Eis gut?
War alles gut?
Die Freude am Sport,
dass die Jugend etwas machen kann.
Die Jugend
muss man mit Sport erziehen.
Du kannst sie nicht
sich selbst überlassen.
Wer in der Ecke sitzt,
ist gefährdet.
Ich freue mich, wenn die Jugend
auf die Eisbahn kommt.
Die Eisbahn ist
von Dezember bis Februar geöffnet.
Otto Zengaffinen kommt morgens
als Erster auf die Anlage
und geht abends als Letzter.
Seine wichtigste Aufgabe ist,
das Eis zu präparieren.
Hier passen 600 l rein.
Das reicht,
um einmal das Eis zu machen,
mit 1 mm Wasser auf dem Eis.
Genau so viel
hoble ich bei einem Durchgang ab.
Gleich viel Wasser kommt dann nach.
So habe ich stets denselben Stand.
Unter der Eisfläche
liegen ein Hartgummifeld
und mehrere Tennisplätze.
Anfang November beginnt Otto,
das Eis aufzubauen.
Schicht für Schicht.
Immer nachts, wenn es kalt ist.
Nach drei Wochen ist es dick genug,
um Regen und höheren Temperaturen
zu trotzen.
Eismachen, sagt Otto,
sei eine Wissenschaft.
Und ein bisschen Magie.
Ich passe mich der Natur an.
Die Natur kann man nicht veräppeln.
Man muss mit dem arbeiten,
was man hat.
Luftfeuchtigkeit,
Kälte, Wärme, Regen, Schnee ...
Es gibt keine Feinde.
Aber das Schlimmste ist, wenn es
drei Tage lang je 10 cm Schnee gibt.
Da kommt man nicht mehr nach.
Kaum ist das Eis bereit,
schneit es erneut.
Dann kam es auch schon vor,
dass ich Petrus
den Finger gezeigt habe.
Ist das gut? Die Maschine geht an.
Im Dorf nennen sie Otto
den Eisflüsterer.
Er mag die Kälte und die Stille.
Es ist ruhig und kalt.
Natürlich wäre ich lieber zu zweit.
Aber im Grossen und Ganzen
mache ich es sehr gerne.
Wenn ich am nächsten Tag
nach Hause gehe,
lässt mich meine tolle Frau
schlafen.
Dann kann ich es auch geniessen.
Otto ist mittlerweile 77 Jahre alt.
Das Eismachen halte ihn jung,
sagt er,
und ein Nachfolger
sei nicht in Sicht.
Seit zehn Jahren
ist es immer mein letzter Winter.
Im Frühling räume ich meinen Spind
und sage: "Jetzt ist Schluss."
Aber ich bin immer noch hier.
Bevor ich morgens um 5 Uhr
Feierabend mache,
müssen die Schläuche
entleert werden.
Sonst sind sie morgen pickelhart.
Das mache ich jetzt.
Nachher gehe ich schlafen.
Otto hofft,
dass es in der Nacht nicht schneit
und er durchschlafen kann.
Morgen früh um 6 Uhr
wird er wieder der Erste sein
auf der Natureisbahn von Saas-Fee.
Es wimmelt von Viertausendern hier.
Der Star unter ihnen:
das Matterhorn.
Wahrzeichen und meistfotografierte
Sehenswürdigkeit der Schweiz.
Zermatt ist nach wie vor autofrei.
Elektrofahrzeuge
haben manche Pferdekutschen abgelöst.
Die Bergbahn auf den Gornergrat
war die erste elektrisch betriebene
Zahnradbahn im Land.
Die Fahrt hinauf
dauert eine gute halbe Stunde.
Vorbei an Wäldern,
Steinschluchten und Bergseen,
mit Blick
auf ein atemberaubendes Panorama.
Endstation auf 3'100 m Höhe.
Das Kulm ist das höchstgelegene Hotel
der Schweizer Alpen.
All inclusive. Restaurant,
Sternwarte und Shoppingmall.
Wenige Kilometer Luftlinie
nordwestlich:
Sion und die Sprachgrenze
mitten im Rhonetal.
Den historischen Stadtkern
überragen zwei Felsen.
Auf dem einen steht die Ruine
des ehemaligen Schlosses Tourbillon,
auf dem anderen die Wallfahrtskirche
Notre-Dame de Valèr.
* Imposante Musik *
Das Schloss wurde beim
grossen Stadtbrand 1788 zerstört.
Richtung Westen zum Genfersee.
Der grösste Teil des linken Seeufers
gehört zu Frankreich.
* Liebliche Musik *
Genf, die internationalste Stadt
der Schweiz.
Ihr Wahrzeichen, der berühmte
Springbrunnen Jet d'eau,
ist in den Wintermonaten
nur tagsüber in Betrieb.
Genf beherbergt über
100 internationale Organisationen.
Und natürlich
den zweiten Hauptsitz der UNO.
Wenn am See die letzten
Nachtschwärmer ins Bett gehen,
beginnt der Arbeitstag
von Jérémy und Frédéric Clerc.
Von Prangins aus fahren die Fischer
jeden Tag um 4 Uhr morgens
hinaus auf den See.
GPS-Daten weisen ihnen den Weg.
* Französisch *
Die Clercs sind v.a. auf Felchen aus.
Die dürfen nur zwischen 3
und 10 Uhr morgens gefischt werden.
Deshalb müssen Vater und Sohn
so früh raus,
um ihren Kunden
frische Ware liefern zu können.
Während der Laichzeit
dürfen die Fischer
drei Monate lang
keine Felchen fangen.
Mutterschaftsurlaub
nennt Frédéric das scherzhaft.
Jetzt haben sich die Bestände
wieder erholt.
Frühmorgens die Netze einholen,
sie am Abend wieder auswerfen.
Die Arbeitstage von Frédéric
und Jérémy Clerc sind lang.
Doch etwas anderes zu machen,
kommt für sie nicht infrage.
Noch dauert es eine Weile, bis
über dem Genfersee die Sonne aufgeht.
* Schiffshorn *
Die Lausanner
Schifffahrtsgesellschaft CGN
verkehrt zwischen den Schweizer
und den französischen Ortschaften
des Lac Léman.
Die Uferpromenade von Lausanne.
Das herausragende Bauwerk der Stadt:
die Kathedrale Notre-Dame.
* Ausruf auf Französisch *
Von ihrem Turm aus
ruft der Nachtwächter
immer zur vollen Stunde die Uhrzeit
in die vier Himmelsrichtungen.
Der Bahnhof von Lausanne.
Hier herrscht rund um die Uhr
Betrieb.
Ein bisschen weiter im Osten:
Montreux.
Bekannt für seine Luxushotels
und fürs Jazzfestival.
Der Brand des Kasinos 1971
inspirierte die Rockband Deep Purple
zu ihrem Welthit
"Smoke on the Water".
Schloss Chillon auf einer Felseninsel
direkt am Ufer des Sees.
Wieder über die Sprachgrenze,
nur 25 km Luftlinie nordöstlich:
das mondäne Gstaad.
Wahrzeichen hier: das Gstaad Palace.
Seit mehr als 100 Jahren
thront es über dem Ort.
Inhaber Andrea Scherz
ist stolz auf die Tradition.
In den Wintermonaten
verleiht er dem ehrwürdigen Haus
mit einem Lichtspiel
einen ganz besonderen Glanz.
Computergesteuert selbstverständlich.
Das Palace ist wie ein Leuchtturm
für Gstaad.
Das gibt Instagram-Fotos,
Fotos des Hotels im Internet,
die Menschen reden darüber.
Die Menschen haben Freude.
Gestern sagte mir eine 80-Jährige:
"Herr Scherz, das ist so schön."
Das Hotel war am Valentinstag rot.
Wir machen den Menschen Freude.
Wir profitieren
von dieser modernen Technologie.
Das Hotel Palace ist d e r
Treffpunkt für die High Society,
die hier im Winter
ihren Urlaub verbringt.
Ein Gast sagte mir einmal:
"Das Palace
ist wie Fels in der Brandung."
Die Welt dreht sich immer schneller.
Aber das Palace steht still, pflegt
die gleichen Werte, ist solid.
Und es ist heute
eines der letzten familiengeführten
Luxushotels in Europa.
Andrea Scherz leitet das Haus seit
20 Jahren, in dritter Generation.
Das ist ein tolles Foto.
Louis Armstrong
mit meinem Grossvater.
Mein Grossvater verstand es,
grosse Stars ins Hotel zu bringen.
Dadurch hat er das Hotel
berühmt gemacht.
Wenn es hiess, Louis Armstrong
trete im Palace auf,
reisten die Menschen
aus Rom, Paris, London an,
um diesen Star hier im Palace
zu sehen.
So wurde das Hotel immer bekannter.
* Piano-Musik und Gesang *
Die Liste der illustren Gäste
ist lang.
Stammgast Michael Jackson wollte
sogar einmal das ganze Hotel kaufen.
Bis heute ist das Palace
der gesellschaftliche Mittelpunkt
von Gstaad.
# I did it my way.
(Englisch)
Hier schon:
In der Hotelküche herrscht hektischer
Betrieb bis tief in die Nacht.
Ein Jugendfreund von Andrea Scherz
ist Küchenchef.
Are you finished with the curry?
Franz Faeh
leitet ein 55-köpfiges Team.
Im normalen Restaurant
essen 90 % der Gäste das,
was auf der Karte steht.
10 % sind Allergiker
und essen nur gewisse Dinge.
Sie mögen etwas nicht
oder sind Vegetarier.
Bei uns ist es umgekehrt:
10 % essen, was auf der Karte steht.
90 % der Gäste essen,
was sie wollen.
Mit verschiedenen Bars
und eigener Diskothek
ist das Hotel auch eine Institution
im Gstaader Nachtleben.
Concierge Stefan Guazzini wird es
in seiner Spätschicht nie langweilig.
(Italienisch)
Auch diese Nacht
wird wieder lang werden im Palace.
Andrea Scherz mag die spezielle
Atmosphäre. Schon von klein auf.
Als kleines Kind
hat mich die Nacht schon fasziniert.
Der Nachtconcierge,
der hier arbeitete,
hiess gleich wie ich: Andrea.
Die Gäste aus aller Welt
haben ihn gekannt.
Er hat für sie Probleme gelöst -
unglaublich.
Ich kam ihn gerne besuchen.
Manchmal erlaubte es meine Mutter,
dass ich morgens um 3 Uhr
den Wecker stellen durfte.
Ich zog mich an und kam hierher.
Ich verbrachte mit ihm
die letzten Nachtstunden,
weil ich von der Nachtarbeit
so fasziniert war. Heute weniger.
* Sanfte Musik *
Ein paar Kilometer
nördlich am Patraflon
ist bereits
eine Skitourengruppe unterwegs.
Die Mühe lohnt sich,
die Aussicht entschädigt
für den anstrengenden Aufstieg.
Der Hof der Familie Zwyssig
auf dem Seelisberg.
Martha Zwyssig steht jeden Morgen
in aller Frühe auf,
um die Kühe zu melken.
Sie bewirtschaftet den Bio-Hof
gemeinsam mit ihrem Sohn Daniel.
Am Morgen ist es speziell. Es gibt
nur wenige Lichter rundherum.
Zuzuschauen, wie der Tag anbricht,
ist interessant.
Es sieht jeden Tag anders aus.
Es ist ruhig.
Es ist noch Nacht. Niemand
ist unterwegs, man ist allein.
Das ist schön.
Ursprünglich gehörte der Hof
Marthas Mann.
Seit seinem Tod vor 16 Jahren ist
die Bäuerin auf sich allein gestellt.
Gemeinsam mit ihren Kindern
hält sie den Betrieb am Laufen.
Seit sechs Jahren
leitet ihr Sohn den Hof.
Allein hätte ich es
nicht machen können.
Aber mit den Kindern zusammen
ging es gut.
Wir haben noch Schwägerinnen
und Schwager, die aushelfen,
wenn es nötig ist.
Ich habe immer Hilfe bekommen,
das ist schön.
12 Std. - von 5 bis 17 Uhr
dauert der Arbeitstag von Martha.
Auch an Sonn- und Feiertagen.
Die 15 Kühe
geben ca. 300 l Milch am Tag.
Es rentiert schon,
v.a. weil wir in Seelisberg
einen guten Milchpreis haben.
Mein Sohn
arbeitet daneben noch Teilzeit.
Darum melke ich hier.
Komm, es gibt Frühstück.
Vier Kälber sind derzeit im Stall.
Das jüngste ist gerade fünf Tage alt.
Die Tiere aufwachsen zu sehen
ist für Martha die grösste Freude
an ihrem Beruf.
Sie kennen mich, das ist schön.
Wenn wir auf die Alp gehen und
mit ihnen reden, kennen sie uns.
Das ist schön.
Jedes Tier ist ...
Das ist wie bei den Menschen.
Die Tiere sind vom Charakter her
vergleichbar.
Gegen 7 Uhr morgens kommt der Wagen
der örtlichen Käserei Aschwanden,
um die vollen Milchkannen zu holen.
Martha ist müde,
sie möchte sich bald zur Ruhe setzen
und wünscht sich
eine Schwiegertochter,
die ihre Arbeit übernehmen kann.
Ich mache es
noch ein bis zwei Jahre.
Es kommt auf die Situation an.
Ich hoffe, er findet eine Frau,
die mithilft.
Dann könnte ich zurückstehen.
Das wäre für mich
eine grosse Erleichterung.
Mein Hobby ist Trachten sticken.
Das habe ich früher oft gemacht.
Das ist in letzter Zeit
oft liegengeblieben.
Das möchte ich machen:
Trachten nähen, Trachten sticken.
Das möchte ich gerne machen.
Die Nacht neigt sich dem Ende zu.
Ein neuer Tag bricht an
in den Städten, Bergen
und Tälern der winterlichen Schweiz.
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Sabine Näpflin - 2020